>>> ZACK.
>> HEY.
I'LL CATCH UP WITH YOU GUYS
LATER, ALL RIGHT?
HEY, CASEY.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE?
>> I KNOW YOU AND THE GUYS
USUALLY HANG OUT AT WAFFLE HOUSE
AFTER YOUR GAMES, SO I FIGURED
YOU WOULD BE HERE.
I HAVE SOMETHING I NEED TO TELL
YOU.
>> WHAT'S UP?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO STATE NEXT
YEAR.
>> HEY!
THESE WAFFLES ARE TOO SMALL!
>> WE HAD A PLAN.
WE WERE BOTH GOING GO TO STATE
THEN MOVE BACK TO TOWN AFTER AND
GET MARRIED.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANTED.
>> NO.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANTED, ZACK.
ALL RIGHT?
I WANT MORE.
MORE THAN STATE, MORE THAN THIS
TOWN.
>> MORE THAN ME.
>> YEAH.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHAT DID I DO WRONG?
>> NOTHING.
I APPLIED TO THIS MUSIC PROGRAM
IN NEW YORK CITY.
I GOT IN.
>> OH, MY GOD.
WHOSE DOG IS THIS?
>> THAT'S MY DOG.
>> AREN'T YOU GOING SAY
ANYTHING?
>> GET THIS DOG OUT OF HERE!
>> I MEAN, WHAT DO YOU WANT ME
TO SAY, CASEY?
CONGRATS?
I'M LOSING THE LOVE OF MY LIFE.
>> I'M JUST THE LOVE OF YOUR
LIFE SO FAR.
YOU'LL FIND OTHER GIRLS.
>> THEY WON'T BE YOU.
I JUST -- I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S
OVER.
WE'VE BEEN TOGETHER SINCE 8th
GRADE.
>> I KNOW.
AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
I DON'T KNOW WHO I AM WITHOUT
YOU.
>> OH, EXCUSE ME!
>> I OWE IT TO MYSELF TO FIND
THAT OUT.
TRUST ME.
THIS WASN'T AN EASY DECISION.
>> YOU'RE MAKING A MISTAKE,
CASEY.
>> WE GOT A 724 IN PROGRESS.
>> MAYBE I AM MAKING A MISTAKE,
BUT ISN'T THAT WHAT GROWING UP
IS?
IT'S ABOUT TAKING THE BIG
CHANCES, MAKING THE BIG
MISTAKES.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S HOW WE BECOME
WHO WE'RE MEANT TO BE.
>> DO IT!
>> I'LL DO IT.
>> IF YOU SAY SO.
>> DO IT!
>> YOU KNOW WHERE I'M PUTTING
>> IF YOU SAY SO.
THESE?
>> YOU KNOW WHERE I'M PUTTING
RIGHT DOWN MY PANTS, BABY.
THESE?
THAT'S WHERE I LIKE IT.
RIGHT DOWN MY PANTS, BABY.
>> I KNOW THIS IS THE RIGHT
THAT'S WHERE I LIKE IT.
DECISION.
>> I KNOW THIS IS THE RIGHT
WHO KNOWS, YOU KNOW, MAYBE A FEW
DECISION.
YEARS FROM NOW, WE'LL FIND EACH
WHO KNOWS, YOU KNOW, MAYBE A FEW
OTHER AGAIN.
YEARS FROM NOW, WE'LL FIND EACH
IF IT'S MEANT TO BE, IT'LL BE.
OTHER AGAIN.
YOU'LL ALWAYS BE MY FIRST LOVE.
IF IT'S MEANT TO BE, IT'LL BE.
NOTHING CAN CHANGE THAT.
YOU'LL ALWAYS BE MY FIRST LOVE.
>> I GUESS.
NOTHING CAN CHANGE THAT.
>> COME HERE.
>> I GUESS.
>> BIG MISTAKE.
>> COME HERE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BIG MISTAKE.
>> FOR WHAT?
>> THANK YOU.
>> EVERYTHING.
>> FOR WHAT?
>> I GUESS THANK YOU TOO.
>> EVERYTHING.
DO YOU NEED A RIDE HOME?
>> I GUESS THANK YOU TOO.
>> NO.
DO YOU NEED A RIDE HOME?
MY DAD DROVE ME.
>> NO.
>> YOU READY TO GO, BABY GIRL?
MY DAD DROVE ME.
>> YEAH, DAD.
>> YOU READY TO GO, BABY GIRL?
>> FREE BIRD GOT TO FLY, SON.
>> YEAH, DAD.
♪♪